il des jours comme ça où la vie
domestique ressemble à du bonheur mais
attention cette belle image d'épinale
brouiller d'un instant à l' au moment
très précis oùes adorables bin auront
décidé de mettre la
pag je fais quand fait des bêtises
ou bien est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
solutionsair de rien ça ça s'appelle une
petite révolution comme dans beaucoup de
familles Véronique chaperon avait
jusqu'il y a 2 ans la main un peu leste
mais voilà la bonne fessé qui ne fait
pas de mal ça finissait par la miner
pour que je m'occupe d'elle et ben elle
me provoquait et puis elle attendait en
fait que je réagisse il stop et ma
réaction c'était ben voilà ça se
terminait par une
fessée on a parlé avec mon mari puis je
lui ai dit est-ce qu'on peut pas essayer
autre chose je me sens vraiment pas bien
dans ce système ça suffit un put plus
une fess plus de sur les doigson
chaperon essaie de faire des émules
autour d'elle pas si facile dans un pays
où 85 % des parents sont favorable au
punition
corporelle chez vous fessé ou pas fessé
oui moioui oui mais alors après je suis
très mal et je cul pas
donc afin de contrer les irréductibles
de la fessée un lobby s développé en
France depuis quelques années pour
demander pas moins le vote d'une noix
qui interdirait châtiment
corporelors je vous fais une petite
image imaginez que vous vous promeneiez
dans la rue et qu'une personne Aggée
vous dérange et que vous la claquiez on
considérait que c'est un déli pourquoi
pas un enfant la fessée appelle encore
de l'avenir pas sûr souvenez-vous du
martinet il é pré il y a quelques années
encore aujourd'hui il est relé là au
rayon des accessoires de nos amis les
bêtes